but what they haven't done names before
no don't you have a show on YouTube when
you review means no you had is that I
think that's an entirely new concept
[Music]
now we're gonna steal this concept
compute e five okay but first actual
mean review deep learning fees welcome
[Music]
I'm joined by Antonia who is a bit of a
meme stirrer himself and today we're
just gonna look at deep learning means
nice let's jump in so oh no that's a
paper that is cold okay being a DL
researcher is not stressed at all that
is incredible how how he says like that
now oh I already
I always knew what he worked of course
yeah yeah there is another way
there was no AI winter engine is so cool
yeah
alright next meme nice meme I guess my
brain is really big
Oh what else is really big I thought you
never asked every reading tough date on
the edge of a really stink
[Music]
big gradients are always good I mean
look at that why wouldn't you want to
land over there that seems much more
interesting than down there perfect I
guess it's an O minus 7 over 4 Wow it's
10 to the minus 7 over 4 that's a best
small excellent the very small absolute
yes hate the scientist he sees a new
[Laughter]
this is this is the old days the old
days yes of scikit-learn it still works
be wealthy
now we must use the plural for
everything the next name please I don't
know this template is a cool template
yes and no to your researchers Bert and
then exhale net
what is xn that so XL net is birds just
train differently okay and it costs like
10 times more straight okay and it's a
bit better how much does it cost
electricity y2 so people have calculated
this to Train one Excel net costs about
DK this insane but as you work 1% better
it's like that is like five PhD students
that's almost the scooter language model
as Excel net I know how much is better
than dirt a bit a bit Oh a bit a bit
that's all Wow
state-of-the-art search our type for
preprint search github for code ask
random idiots on Facebook in some ways
actually it is simpler to publish
something on archive and not being
completely like people just saying stuff
like that because they're probably good
unnoticed probably gets unnoticed right
yeah no Facebook it doesn't get
unnoticed yeah that's you have a real Q
review exactly if you are in a very good
mean page on Facebook about deep
learning you're gonna get rekt
yes exactly nice that's not gonna happen
this software engineer design a chat
board to chat with his girlfriend why
he's busy at work
however the girl eventually got
suspicious over the speed she was
receiving messages from her boyfriend
modern problems require modern solutions
they're also like pretty good chat BOTS
that's just suspicious with the Piney
help order for the actual content
well fashion companies try to sell us
what we really want fashion and mist
fashion Emmys this is the new cool thing
so cool does anyone use it by the way I
found a huge saddle point nice mmm is
that oh it is not very Nemus where is it
how much accuracy do you get on fashion
like MSM this is so easy like basically
a doneness
I don't know I'm not a fashion person so
I don't know what to call this what move
it no this is a pants with the boys
after using drop out oh I don't know
where they come from where do they come
from this no it's some comic they are so
so beautiful are you still watching
machine learning tutorials on YouTube do
you check my internet history
why can't you watch porn like a normal
tire and drew Angie what is this Andrew
ng I must use more Kerris code yes
please what is wrong with you cuz Andrew
ng boy I know sir but I understand
you're respected in LA he does he says
it's okay if I don't understand
everything yeah
we're as important it's completely
different not okay wait what was the
plot why when your binary classifier
produced with the 1% accuracy it ain't
much but it's all that's what you want
to get random exam change your random
seed until you get 5,200 if their method
works yes exactly and also like you know
buddy finance but actually
state-of-the-art right in work in
finance reduction of the last you have a
profit on things if you if you predict
the last night next time point as the
new as the last time for that's that's
probably the best thing you can do I'm
going to switch my PhD topic yeah they
look like some people with their fancy
methods do works because of this embed
and just because it's just like you just
predict whatever was very new good
okay next me next
- better than using double I will start
with you know this math MATLAB big
learning tool box yeah recently they
introduced new neurons neuronal stuff
like with the networks yeah and the
graphs which is basically as the brain
yeah and so basically you can learn
stuff with MATLAB with MATLAB exactly
Wow exactly can you learn to uninstall
it
I look like all you need go look like an
idiot I dunno that's what we really want
exactly me I sure hope my models error
rate isn't super high and sorry sorry
optimization is hard
yeah it's all you do is advanced methods
and then there's SGD yeah it beats you
every time yeah that's better
me and the boys about received the
Turing award me and the boys so fancy
yeah look at them it's probably thinking
about capsules yeah oh oh but wasn't it
like two years ago yeah yeah what is the
fate of all this is still thinking about
it
okay I didn't get what what happened
well they sold out for different oh
they're different yeah okay so yeah
they're not like the same ah so that
means that they were kinda another way
yes but only do other things sort of but
can they do it on the same task ah I see
no they're like trying to abstract
concepts into these capsules and then
the capsules can route the information
to other capsules
yeah does he work right kind of we kind
of works yeah uh-huh
who's why are people okay like you can
make it do something okay capsules
capsules and that's me my desires are
unconventional so r-tx
2060 2017 and 2018 so bad like use a
transformer in lsdm hey I failed you
know Ireland's must come back
yes exact or incomplete not assistant
remember this location okay
I remember that what did I ask you to
remember I remember what you told me
this location what does this location
means these are the top results
machines are about to take over the
world
this is this intelligence yeah exactly
yeah we must be very very careful
also with jobs and stuff what what what
you finish the meat not yet there's one
more so I have to preface this so
basically this is a so the robots
supposed to get the ball to the target
and in one setting it has a reference
motion of the human doing the same thing
yeah so it learns to learn from that and
then there for a comparison there is no
reference motion and it just learns from
scratch so first is with and I three
times and then without with reference
motion nice and now without
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes yes we are a I do yes Donald damage
is done yeah I mean I I can see an army
of robots they just take the bullet all
right this was episode one of deep
learning me review thanks so much for
being here with us and have a good time
[Music]